the report Brands the Metropolitan
Police internal discipline system has
systematically flawed racist misogynist
too slow and ineffective the evidence
around racial disparity in the
metropolitan's policies misconduct
system is so grave and so shocking that
even in 2021 81 of black staff and
officers are more likely to be in the
misconduct system than their white
counterparts is truly awful what I'm
saying is the internal misconduct system
is an example of what I would call
institutional racism the report found
that black staff were 81 percent more
likely than white to face a missed
conduct allegation sexual and other
discrimination complaints were less
likely than others to be investigated
misconduct cases took an average 400
Days to be resolved and 20 percent of
accused staff were involved in two or
more cases
the report highlights the case of one
officer who faced 11 misconduct hearings
over sexual harassment assault fraud and
other allegations some were proved some
were dismissed he kept his job and is
still a serving officer the report said
up to 60 percent of misconduct
allegations were dismissed leaving staff
who complained feeling that nothing
happens we've been sacking a bit less
than one a week so maybe 40 or 50 a year
um
based on this report which clearly says
that we have been far too soft
um there must be hundreds in the
organization that I need to get rid of
some of them are unethical and don't
deserve to be a cop and
don't deserve to wear in uniform and
some of what they're doing in many cases
is Criminal a former met officer said
accused police should not get special
treatment I think it's absolutely
appalling that the police are not held
to the same standards as members of the
community are and the fact that they can
get away with one offense two offenses
or three offenses without going to court
and without losing their jobs is
appalling and that will affect trust and
confidence with the many communities of
London the home office said it would
review the whole police disciplinary
process the full Casey review of the
Mets culture and standards of behavior
is expected to be published in the New
Year Martin brunt Sky News Scotland Yard